hello everybody I'm so lucky today to be
joined by one of this I think this
century's most prolific makeup artist I
will say you are definitely know you are
you know what Patrick you are literally
in the glamour office and I've said this
to you before but I like to say it on
camera we're literally obsessed with you
we love all the work you do we love your
Instagram I mean it's literally for me
it's like a lookbook
of like you know what I mean like of
endless inspiration I mean we're not the
only ones obsessed with him I mean you
just have to think about like all the
girls that you do I mean the red carpet
gorgeousness is out of control just so
many beautiful women you work with and I
want to get your secrets and can't you
you want to tell them to promise okay
let's be real for a minute I mean
obviously we're not going to name names
but you work with all these amazing
girls they are stressed they come off
planes they sleep three hours they don't
always have permanently perfect skin do
they no I mean I mean they're just like
anyone else like they go through like
they make it like a break out here and
there and I mean it's my job to make
them look gorgeous and they do look
gorgeous though we're obviously here
today also with one of my favorite
brands Lemaire I mean I've but the thing
is like I talked about the mayor so
often and the fact that I've been using
you know the moisturizing cream like
forever and it's my kind of like SOS
emergency product so the thing is when I
look at your makeup yes
colors gorgeous you know all everything
definition and so on that's always the
skin that is literally the thing we get
most obsessed with I'll say I love like
just focusing on skin because I feel
like it's it takes I mean it takes up
the majority of the face and I feel like
if I'm gonna invest time into something
it's like it's not the eyes it's not the
lips it's about it's the skin because I
really feel like when you really take
time to blend out skin to make skin look
like skin it just makes girls shine and
glow and look radiant when when you do
have like I guess you have limited time
sometimes especially for the red carpet
it's like boom boom boom how much time
of like a whole makeup session do you
think you take over with skincare so
it's gonna carry probably like 25
minutes to really just like work in all
the products and just to really make the
skin just ready for the makeup
application and what is your I mean
obviously I guess it depends on people's
skin as well whether they have oily skin
or more dehydrated dry skin but what
would be like your kind of steps which
products would you are the what like
your go-to because there's a lot of
products in the range so well right now
it's so amazing because the mirror has
so many moisturize which one to two okay
so I'm gonna grab them all really quick
there's just so many we have the
original creme and this one is just the
baby of lemare and this one is very very
hydrating so this is for people who have
their who are on like the drier side so
if you really need that extra just like
burst of moisture I really recommend to
use this but as far as what I'm doing
makeup I like the gel moisturizer the
gel moisturizer is great for men and
women just because it's more lightweight
and it but it really does the job of
moisturizing and it leaves your skin a
little bit tacky just so that when you
apply foundation it just sticks onto the
skin and it grips onto the skin exactly
I love that word so the foundation like
doesn't go anywhere and obviously when
I'm doing makeup for these clients they
want their makeup to last they want the
makeup to stay and just like their
everyday woman at home like if you are
applying makeup in the morning you don't
want to have to reapply later throughout
throughout throughout the day where does
one strategically powder know so we just
came out with the pressed powder from
the mirror and there's a difference
between looking oily and dewy and you
don't ever want to look orally so you
want to look dewy you want to look fresh
you want like glow you want to look
luminous and the way that you do that is
you always want to powder just the
center of the face especially around
your smile lines on your chin on the
peak of your forehead and I just
to leave the perimeter of the face nice
and not for and Dewey just because when
light hits you when the cameras hit you
you want that part - like really capture
the light and just like just to be
manned so people can just see like my
skin is gorgeous
and I mean that's amazing I think I've
learned so many little tips and tricks
but if you had to give real everyday
women who you know like I said we do our
makeup in the morning it has to last all
day long it has to last into the night
what would be like your top top tip to
have beautiful radiant makeup all day
long my top tip for having beautiful
radiant and makeup all day long is to
just to invest in a great foundation the
foundation should last you a pretty long
time like if if your foundation doesn't
last more more than five hours like you
gotta get any one last question shade
selection with Foundation does Patrick
Tarr match the skin or this Patrick Todd
go a little bit of warmer eyes makeup
artist like I like to just keep a few
colors and I just mix them I mix them
and put them on on everybody and also I
think that's good because I think you
should definitely have at least two
shades yeah because you're never gonna
be your neighbor one shade throughout
the year so now we've got to say goodbye
to you but I'm gonna get Patrick to
hopefully shade matchy getting no okay
okay
desperado thank you bye guys
you